[Music]
welcome to the data base in the data
analytics session this is of course a
very important area but not an in Delhi
new area but today we have three
excellent speakers and they're going to
talk about some of the new very new
directions that the field is taking so
one common thread among them is the
intersection of this field with some of
the techniques in machine learning the
first two talks that we are going to
hear are going to be around leveraging
some of these deep analytic techniques
for some of the classical database
operations and challenges the last talk
is going to focus on saying how can data
analytic platforms who are of course for
a long time and traditionally have been
used to understand what the data is what
the insights in the data is can more
easily adapt to the challenges of doing
machine learning on these platforms so
with these three talks you're going to
see both dimensions of the work that's
going on in the field which is quite new
so with that we are going to start with
the first speaker who is an v-power law
professor and Apollo is in CMU and he is
a leader of the data base group and the
parallel delivers laboratory there he's
a winner of the Sigma 2014 Jim Gray
dissertation award as well as the SLO on
research philosophy award for 2018 and
ACM sigmod best paper award in addition
to doing excellent and innovative work
in delivery systems Andy is one of the
most you know entertaining speaker and
he has promised us to kick off this
session on a high note with that Andy
take it away that's all I promised you
that I wouldn't get you fired that's
what I promised that promise is also
very important and my manager is in the
audience so I have to be particularly
careful right okay all right thanks all
right so today's talk I want to talk
about so that you know research we've
been doing at Carnegie Mellon in the
context of how to build autonomous or
self-driving database systems
so by autonomous I mean a database
that's able to configure tune and
optimize itself automatically without
any human intervention
so there's another talk I could give
about the machine learning methods and
algorithms
used to make this happen instead this
talk I want to talk about the things you
need to have when you're building your
database system in order to make it
amenable to being tuned by it's no
autonomous component or planning
framework so the way to sort of think
about this is for this talk is like
these are the engineering problems we
have to overcome in order to have the
machinery stop be able to control us
right it doesn't matter how great
machine learning algorithms are how much
training data you have if you actually
cannot expose the right interfaces or
API to those planning frameworks and
then take the actions that they suggest
and apply them then all it's for nothing
so today's talk I'm gonna break up the
three parts so first would talk about
some background of what works been done
in the context of autonomous databases
for the last 40 years and then we'll
talk about more of the engineering side
of things again how to support Tom's
operation and then what kind of data
base talk would I give if we didn't
finish off with a rant about Oracle
right so we'll finish up with that so
the the idea of a Thomas databases are
almost as old as databases themselves
right the the first relational database
is when they came out in the 1970s
immediately people recognized that there
was a need for these systems being to
adapt themselves and optimize the the
performance of storage and indexing
without having a human tell at
everything so back then in the 1970s
this line of work was called self
adaptive systems right and they did
things like picking indexes is probably
the most common one so two high level
these early self adaptive tools will
work a lot like they work today you have
some human prepare a workload trace of
previous queries that the application
application is executed and then you're
gonna feed them into your tuning
algorithm but then is gonna crunch on
them compute some kind of internal
statistics about the you know the
problem you're trying to solve so if you
trying to pick indexes you'll figure out
what columns are accessing those often
in queries and then you use this
internal total cost model to evaluate a
bunch of candidate actions or candidate
indexes and then weight them accordingly
and then the tool rep would spit out a
recommendation to a human who then had
to make the final decision about how and
when to apply it to the database so at a
high level again all of these sort of
self adaptive tools work essentially the
same way right so they handle things
like index election and data
partitioning and sharding and data
placement
so just give you an idea how old this
problem is there's a paper in 1976 on
doing self adaptive systems for index
election and this paper was actually
written by my advisers advisor who's now
dead right so this can people be
thinking about this for a long time so
now the next certain major trend or
chapter in autonomous systems came along
in the the nineteen late 1990s and
2000's and this is sort of entered the
era what I'll call for self tuning
database systems and again at Ohio these
tools are essentially doing the same
thing you take some workload trace
crunch on them and they spit out
recommendations so all the major vendors
at this time had their own proprietary
tools to solve these types of problems
I'm not just saying this because we're
here at Microsoft but it's my opinion
that the auto admin project by Marcus
off was that the van got really at the
forefront of this there's a lot of
groundbreaking work that we're actually
building on today that came out of this
project and the seminal paper would be
this 2007 paper from from from surgit
they sort of talked about the the
decade's worth of work they did on this
project so the other thing we saw in the
self tuning systems around this time was
the need to do knob configuration so
knob would be like a a a configuration
parameter you could set in the system to
control the runtime behavior of the
database like how much memory to use for
your buffer pool so the reason why there
we had there was now a need for
automatic tools to be able to configure
these things is because the number knobs
of these systems actually supported kept
increasing and things were getting more
complex to give you an idea how bad it
is one of my students went and look it
took the two major open-source databases
my Sikkim postgres and went back 15
years and looked at all the different
releases and counted the number of knobs
that they had and then over a 15-year
period
Postgres increased the number knobs by
5x and my sequin crease the number knobs
they had by 7x so at this point like you
know this is well beyond what any human
can reason about and so there's
automated tools that are needed to make
this happen so now we see in the 2010s
will i'll call when we enter the era of
cloud manage databases and this is that
exactly we just saw in this keynote
where it was not so much about how to
tune individual databases was now at a
service provider level how to
essentially do a bin packing problem
right how do
to place the tenants on the various
harbours that you have available in
order to maximize the the performance
while minimizing your hardware costs and
you may need to actually migrate things
over time so this is again this is doing
autonomous databases but at the service
provider level or the operator level
where you're not actually tuning
individual databases you're just looking
at thousands and thousands of tenants
and trying to decide what's the best way
to lay them out so now given I just
spent you know this time beginning talk
about the last 40 years of autonomous
databases why do i why is all this work
that that's people have done before why
is this insufficient for achieving for a
fully autonomous system and I'll say
there's three reasons why this this is
not it's not entirely what we need so
the first is that a lot of these tools
still require human to make a final
judgment about the recommendations or
suggestions from these these tuning
tools but I say human had to look and
say well it's asking me to build this
index is that they're actually the right
thing for me to do and then the human
actually had to then decide when was the
right time to deploy that suggestion and
and how should they deploy it so they'd
have to know that like 3:00 a.m. on the
Sunday is when my I have the lowest
amount of demand so that's when I go
ahead and start optimizing things the
next problem is that these are all
reactionary measures where a lot of are
reactionary meaning they look at the
workload trace in the past identify
problems and try to call up suggestions
and we're going to avoid them in the
future
they're not looking down the road
looking at various trends and saying
well this is my what my workloads gonna
look like a week from now or a month
from now and prepare the system
accordingly and this is essential what
humans are doing now right the new
capacity planning based on what they
think is a workload is gonna look like
in the future and the last problem is
that they're not be able to transfer any
of the knowledge that they learn from
tuning one particular database and apply
it to another database so what that
means is that say I run my tuning tool
or my single database instance and then
I come along with an another application
I want to tune its database for unless
that application is exactly you know it
has exactly the same workload on the
exact same Hardware you're not you can't
reuse anything you learn from from the
first time you ran it so these are the
reasons why I think these all the
existing work is not enough to be in
order to have a full
autonomous system so now you may be
asking why am I so confident that it's
gonna be different this time so I would
say that the reason why I'm optimistic
about our building to have a fully
autonomous system is essentially the
same story at why machine learning is
hot now right we have the storage
capacity actually store a lot of
training data and then we have better
frameworks like torch and tensorflow
they're gonna crunch on it and then we
have hardware accelerators like GPUs and
CPUs available to us they're able to
take a large amounts of training data
and and derive the models that that we
need so this is why I'm sort of bullish
on this area and I think that there's a
lot of interesting techniques from
machine learning and the IEEE community
that we can apply for our databases to
essentially complete the circle from
what people have done in the past so
give me give me an idea with this sort
of some of these projects look like once
talked about two things we've been
building at Carnegie Mellon for the last
couple years the first is this thing
called auto-tune which is a knob
configuration tuning service and this is
designed to work on existing systems
like sequel server my sequel Postgres
and sort of treating them as a black box
and trying to figure out what can we
what information can be derived from
them to help tune their knobs better and
then we have another database system
called peloton we'll be building this
from scratch where the idea is to take a
sort of a clean slate approach at
designing a database system in order to
make it be managed by an autonomous
system so I'll briefly go over each of
these one by one so as I said auto-tuned
is a database knob tuning as a service
the idea is you come along with your
database installation you connect it to
its service you upload some metrics we
crunch on them and then spit back a knob
recommendation and then we apply that
observe your changes and see whether
that helps and sort of this feedback
loop you get better and better the key
difference about auto tune than all the
previous work is that we can actually
reuse the information or the data we've
collected from previous tuning sessions
to help speed up tuning newer sessions
so that means if you come along with
your application and we've never seen it
before but we collect some metrics and
we look to see oh it actually looks very
similar to this other application we
tuned in the past since we know how to
tune that one now we know how to tune
yours so just as a quick show what kind
of forms we can get so we did a simple
experiment where we took my C compost
grass we ran the TPC
benchmark on a small instance on Amazon
and we're gonna compare what auto-tune
can do against the default configuration
you get for these systems versus some
open source tuning scripts or the
configuration you get from Amazon when
you run an RDS and then lastly we're
also gonna compare it against a very
expensive human DBAs tuning these two
systems manually so in the case of my
Seco what you see is that the auto-tune
and the DBA actually perform better than
all the other approaches now the reason
why the DBA actually beats us here is
because this is the top my Seco DBA from
Facebook and the sum knob and my sequel
that effects whether you flush every
right when you commit a transaction or
how aggressive you flush things and at
Facebook they were okay we're turning
that feature off so that allows you get
a little bit better performance this is
actually a important point when we talk
about the engineering side because this
actually is a human judgment that has to
be made about whether it's okay to
reduce the durability of of your of your
transactional data so we blacklisted
this knob from auto-tune so we just so
we purposely said it's not a lot of tune
this and then that's why the DBA was
actually able to beat us in the case of
Postgres we see the auto-tune actually
does does better than all the other
approaches and this is because it's able
to find sort of the sweet spot for this
particular workload and hardware
configuration for tuning the buffer pool
size there's the log file size right and
this again we're up against a very
seasoned DBA and we're able to beat them
okay the main thing here is that we're
auto-tune is doing as good if not better
than very expensive human DBAs with only
training for about for about an hour now
the next project is peloton we're
pitching this as the self driving
database system meaning that we want
this thing to be entirely autonomous so
we're building this from the ground up
to be entirely you know to be controlled
by this self driving framework we've
been building and the idea here is that
we want to see where you know what
advantage do we have when we have
complete control of the entire system it
allows us to do things that we could not
easily do with auto-tune and it will say
is that we actually considered maybe
using my seagull or Postgres initially
for this project but we found is that
there's just way too many things that
require the system restore
have other problems that make it not
amenable for self-driving operation so
we decided look like the bullet and
write a system from scratch and there's
a whole other talk I could give about
the trials and tribulations of building
a database system from scratch in
academia which has been quite a journey
so now I want to talk about what again
what I'm calling the design
considerations for autonomous operation
so again the idea here is that how
should you build a database system in
order to support itself or have it self
be able to be controlled by you know
planning framework that wants to run
entirely autonomously so for this the
reoccurring theme that we see over and
over again is that these these engineer
usage ins we can make are gonna help us
help us reduce the complexity of the
solution space for our Thomas planning
components right because otherwise we
need a lot of training data in order to
compute rain these models and it'll take
a long time for them and converge to a
good solution so there's some tricks we
can do just to reduce the number of
choices we have to consider and maximize
the reuse of the training data that we
want to build upon and that allows us to
get better optimizations more quickly so
I'll first talk to start talking about
configuration knobs and metrics so the
idea is here is what API or do you
expose to the the planning framework and
then we'll talk about how do you take
the actions that the planning framework
suggests and apply them in an efficient
manner without slowing down the rest of
the system all right so the most
important thing you have to have for
your figuration knobs is the ability to
mark which ones should or should not be
tuned by your autonomous components
right we saw this before when we talked
about the Facebook DBA right there's
some flag that Facebook allowed that
their DBA set that we decide that we
weren't gonna set in our Thomas
components because a human had to make a
final value judgment about whether it
was okay to do that okay so some things
are obvious right like file paths
network addresses and port numbers but
if you don't set these things and the
system doesn't doesn't boot properly at
all but things like durability and
isolation levels these are actually
judgments that have to be made by the
company organization about whether that
was an okay thing to do right is it okay
to turn off s Inc when you commit a
transaction
right are you okay with losing meme to
last 10 or 20 milliseconds worth of
transaction data some places that's okay
some places that's not okay but the
machine learning algorithms aren't going
to know that there's some other more
nuanced things like harbour usage like
how aggressive do you want to be doing
compaction if you have an L SM because
this will cause you to wear down the
device more quickly and have to buy it
new hardware or recovery time is another
one like do you do how long are you
willing to have the system be able to
you know take the recover if there's a
crash we can't we can't control these
things or we can't know these things in
our machine learning model cost models
so we have to have a human just to be
able to tell this and we have them
therefore we to blacklist them and
that's one is that we need now hints
about how we should actually tune these
knobs and again this is necessary to
again to reduce the search space or
solution space of the actions that we
could apply in our system so the most
obvious one is our min max ranges for a
parameter right what's the you know how
many how much how much memory should I
be able to allow to allocate to a buffer
pool there's other things we see that
any time you have a knob where you that
you think can't be controlled
meaning turn it on and off you should
always separate them from the actual
knob that controls its behavior so
sometimes we see knobs where you can you
can rate limit how much how fast is
gonna write data out the disk in terms
of kilobytes but a lot of times I'll use
a special value like negative one or
zero to disable that feature and the
problem is the machine machine learning
algorithms will find that setting the
you know the amount of data are writing
out the disk to zero kilobytes makes you
go faster of course that now that means
you're not running and data to disk and
you're gonna lose data so if you just
have a separate boolean flag to control
it separately from the actual parameter
that makes things easier another more
nuance one is is the ability to control
how you actually modify these these
values or knobs so in those cases are in
most systems we've seen you can set
absolute values for for a certain
parameter look how much remember you
want to use for your buffer pool you can
set it from 0 to 2 to the 32 we think
the better way to do this is just
increment have increments that can based
on a delta to go up and down for these
parameters and that cuts down the number
actions you have to consider but now the
problem is
if you have a you know a large range of
values could you could you could choose
then in committing by a fixed amount
over you know throughout that entire
range causes problems so what you really
want is non-uniform Delta's like this so
say if I want to set the amount of
memory music my buffer pool if I've
between one kilobyte and one megabyte
maybe just increment by 100 kilobytes at
a time right but if I'm up to one
terabyte of DRAM I don't want to
increment by one kilobytes because it's
not gonna make a big difference from
from one setting to the next so you can
even expose the deltas to the tuning
algorithms and say only increment by
these values when you within these
ranges now the next thing we're going to
talk about is how do you expose metrics
or information to the outside system I'm
gonna use these to build our cost models
and do more calculations for our actions
we can choose so the most important
thing we find is that anytime your
database system supports the ability to
tune individual sub components you want
to make sure you expose individual
metrics for those sub components so an
example would be in like db2 for
existence ette the number of buffer
pools you want every CH but for pool you
can tune them separately and you need to
make sure that for each buffer pool all
the stats you you care about are exposed
to you and not sort of aggregated
together the biggest offender we find is
actually for this as rocks DB so in
rocks DB you can set for each table can
have multiple column families and you
tuned each column family in individual
individually so they do is expose they
do expose some metrics about each column
family but the problem is the most
important thing you need to determine
whether your performances that get
better or worse are the number of reads
and writes per column family but they're
not included in the in this sort of the
sub component metrics instead you can
only get this from from a global metric
table where it's been combined together
so now you need a lot of training data
in order to to determine whether the
changes you're making to one particular
column family is benefiting or hurting
you because you have to then extract
that from the the aggregated metric so
now we talk about how do you actually
take the actions that the album select
and apply them efficiently so the most
important thing I would say and part of
the reason why with peloton we decided
to build a system from scratch is that
we find that many cases
changing a knob or applying an action
requires you to restart the system in
order that to take effect now the
commercial systems are much better than
this then the open-source guys but even
you know the sequel server Oracle and
db2 there's enough knobs in there that
require you to have to restart the
reason why that's problematic because
now you need to take into consideration
in your cost models the the time it
takes to restart the system or you have
to ask a human whether it's okay to
restart the system right now so we think
that there should be never any knob that
will require you have to restart and
this includes scaling up the hardware as
well as applying you know changes that
modify how it actually uses the hardware
another very important thing is that you
want to have the ability to have your
replicas converge or diverge and have
different configurations in order to get
more training data about the different
configurations you could have it's a
very common set up in databases is that
you for high availability you have a
master and some replicas right and
anytime the master goes down then you
elect one of the replicas become the new
master so normally you would have these
things have the exact same configuration
because any time the master goes down
you want the replicas I'll be able to
come up right away but instead what you
can do to get more training data you
could have the master have the best
configuration configuration you ever
seen but then your replicas you're
trying out other configurations see
whether they're actually better than
then what's on the master right now so
in this case here the replicas can be
trying out different index selections
and seeing whether they're actually
improving performance so let's say for
this top guy here this is actually doing
better then we can recognize that it's
okay for us to deploy this on the master
right the reason why we want to do this
in the replicas because we don't want to
slow down the the master node because we
need to meet our SLA s and SL loaves so
now the problem is though let's say that
this bottom guy here we're trying out a
configuration that actually is bad and
therefore we're falling behind the the
workload that's on the master right so
if we recognize now if we're too far
behind we want to go ahead and kill that
configuration and restart the system
because we don't want to have to crash
if the master crashes we don't want our
replicas have to take five minutes to
get caught back up okay now that's
downtime we have to include in our
system yes perfect so there's a bunch of
other stuff you have to consider for
this like you know can you if you're in
a class
can you scale out additional BMS collect
more training data how do you jitter the
workload so your input sequence to the
replicas are different right there's a
whole bunch of systems questions to
actually make this work I think it's
interesting so to finish up let's talk
about Oracle so you might have seen this
announcement last year well Oracle came
out and says we have the world's first
self-driving database minute system
Larry Ellison got on stage and he said
this is the most important thing that
the Oracle Oracle Corporation has worked
on in the last 20 years so the only
thing about this announcement is that we
had a paper in January a few months
before but we will talk about our
self-driving database system right and
at no point did Larry Ellison mention
our work so I decided to you know shoot
him an email but like hey look what's up
with that right now you may be thinking
it's a bit puerile for a professor to
email somebody say hey why didn't you
cite our work but Larry Ellison LIGO go
pretty far back and so I thought it was
okay for me to email and let him know
that I was slightly displeased with this
now he didn't respond his email he never
responds to any of my emails but that's
ok we can still we can still break it
down and see what he's actually done so
there are self-driving database claims
they have four key features they do
automatic indexing recovery scaling and
query tuning now for the first three
items here these are essentially the
same things the same solving the same
kind of problems that the self-tuning
databases were solving in the 2000s
right and so in talking with the Oracle
developers and reading their marketing
material as far as I can tell these are
just the same tools that they've been
selling before as DBAs for the DBAs but
now just running them in a managed
environment so that means they have the
same limitations or problems that I
talked about before where they're
reactionary and they're not able to do
knowledge transfer so for this reason I
don't think this is actually really a
self-driving databases right they're
just running your stuff automatically
and sort of playing tricks I meet the
covers and make it look like it's it's
you know fully adaptive and self driving
so now from the second last one
automatic query tuning if you're
familiar with the work in academic
literature this is usually referred to
as adaptive query processing but the
idea is if you have a very expensive
query you run through optimized
when you first start generate a query
plan and if you noticed over time as
you're running it things are not it's
not as good as you thought it was then
you run through the optimizer again so
this is not unique to Oracle right
Microsoft announced last year and sequel
server 2017 that they have the same
feature but it's even older than that
right if you go back into the early
2000s IBM db2 had a project called leo
the learning optimizer where they were
essentially doing the same kind of thing
but it's even older than the IBM project
it actually goes back to the 1970s with
the first one of the first relational
databases ingress where they were
essentially do running the query
optimizer over and over again for every
single tuple you would examine but they
did this not because they were trying to
be sophisticated they were doing this
because they had a really primitive
query optimizer so again in this case
here there's nothing really unique about
what Oracle is claiming they can do and
I wouldn't say this is this is self
driving at all so what I will say though
about Oracle is in talking with the
developers they are working on a newer
version of this that is certain
corporates and the things that I'm
talking about here so to finish up I
think that Thomas databases are
achievable in the next decade I think
it's a lot of engineering work a lot of
systems research and a lot of machine
learning stuff we can apply to sort of
make this thing all work and I would say
for anybody that's working on a large
system they they wonder have be used why
there either it's in academia or an
industry anytime you add a new feature
you should not think about how how is it
human gonna tune this you should really
be thinking about how can a machine tune
this in efficient manner am i exposing
the right information and the right
controls that necessary to make this
thing work
so with that I'll finish up and I don't
think have any questions right because
we're doing panels okay thank you
thanks Andy just hang in for a second
let's see if there are a couple of
pointed questions that anybody in the
audience has for Andy before the memory
of the talk face a bit with the next two
talks so if you have any question though
raise your hand
are there arañas we'll get you a
microphone because these talks are being
recorded yes I'll just repeat the
question makes it easier yeah Andy
thanks for the great talk um so you
mentioned a bunch of driving factors
there being like available from new
hardware and available of new
interesting ways of doing more powerful
models such as Steve Nets but I mean
from from my experience one of the big
differentiators has also availability of
new data or or more data that allows us
to do better training and therefore
build better and more expressive models
and so I'm wondering where do you get
your data from and you have any
interesting insights of how to do better
and more targeted data collection and
selection for training better models in
this context all right so this question
is that so Johanna says arguing that the
having a lot of training data is the is
the key thing to having you know models
that actually can can we can derive use
from so what are some things we can do
to improve our collection of training
data that correct okay so the the one
thing I said before is about this
example here like if you use your
replicas to try out different
configurations this is collecting more
training data right but this is sort of
getting you know this is helping you to
converge to see whether you're actually
getting benefit from the choices you
make in terms of the actual metrics I
think that I mean you you essentially
the systems are doing monitoring now we
just make sure that we push them out and
build out our models based on them so
there's not really anything in terms of
what metrics you collect not really
anything in there that's different than
what existing systems do now in the case
of auto-tune we don't actually need to
look at the queries or the actual data
itself we just take the metrics you know
the internal performance counters that
the system generates and spits them out
the other thing I'll say though is a lot
of times developers just
and whenever metric they think of right
so there's a there's a lot of data in
you know that there's actually not
really useful and so we have statistical
methods to sort of prune out the things
that actually don't matter and you sort
of focus on the main ones and they made
sort of you know finding the signal in
the noise in that way Carl oh yes
recently so I think Carla's question is
how how should academics engage with
major cloud vendors like like Microsoft
and try to apply some these techniques
in in your environment I would say that
so this is sort of why I sort of divided
my two projects and taking existing
systems versus like the voting system
from scratch I for the for the kind of
tuning we want a hand on auto-tune you
need to have the source code you need
complete control of everything so I I
think you know for you guys to be hard
too hard to do this plus it you know
sequel server is a huge codebase I think
that's something you guys have to do
in-house with autotune since we're just
looking at sort of treating the debut
system as a black box
I think interns are probably the right
way to do this I think that I think that
we've learned enough about sequel server
now and other systems that we can come
to you guys and say hey if you
these features but I think it's gonna
take longer than the things we're going
to ask you for is gonna take longer than
you can do on a summer internship so I
don't know what the right approach is
for that I would just add one small
thing that it is true that we get a lot
of telemetry data yes there's no
question but as you know we are not
allowed to look at the data or the
workload so there is you know even
though there is a lot of data in our
cloud service somewhere yes we are not
entitled to look at it the query string
or actual data unless you know the
customer has raised a ticket and there
for a limited time in an audited way
somebody looks at it right so it comes
with the other balancing thing on our
ability to look at you know in a
classical way to look at all the data
like being or Google can do we can do I
think just wanted to add that as an
aside I will say that again just like I
mean I'm not just here because he's here
yeah just the way that auto admin was
sort of the leader in this area in the
2000s in my visits with with companies I
think Microsoft again is and the cloud
area is leading this effort right imesh
surprised at how primitive some of the
things that are that are out there and
in major cloud vendors in this area well
last question
thanks Andy and then maybe the last
question we can't hear you
but I think the microphone is not on I
think that I can hear you
so my question was that you mentioned
that there was an increase in the number
of configuration knobs in these various
database engines by about a factor of
five over the years but it's likely that
most of the features don't really affect
the performance as such right in the
sense that the same three or four
important parameters it was there ten
years back would probably be the same
ones that you have right now so actually
only the dbl needs to look at those
parameters and the rest of them are just
as you mentioned noise amongst the
signal and if you're using machine
learning techniques it's likely that you
will introduce many new features that
are actually not relevant towards the
final goal of optimizing the system for
performance so this question is that in
this graph here I'm showing that there's
hundreds of knobs but in actuality most
them are probably not something that a
DBA is gonna tune actively or tune for
the daily job and then then you were
saying that if now we start introducing
you know interfacing the Davis system
with machine learning pieces or
machining components that's gonna
introduce more knobs and more complexity
and how do we handle that
so first the first one I would say that
what we do in in in auto-tune is that we
we basically run a similar lots of
aggression and figure out here's the
ranking of the knobs that actually
matter the most for variety of workloads
and you're right it's about 25 or so but
I would say that it's it's more than the
number knobs it's the dependencies
between them and that just makes the
problem you know it's just this morning
much more difficult so then the second
thing you said was that adding in
machine learning parts this makes this
thing even even harder to tune I would
say but yes but these are things not
that these are things I means my lofty
research goals I think we can automate
all of us I don't think we actually need
humans to do very very much other than
to give us a credit card number and some
initial hints about how to tune things I
don't think there's anything that we
would need a human to tune these things
for so that's that's my goal whether we
get there you know in 10 years I'd like
to think we can but we'll see well on
that high note yes thank you Andy thank
you
[Applause]
so our next speaker is Professor Tim
Kroshka from MIT Tim you know has been
in our field of database systems for a
long time and his research has focused
in the past on hybrid I guess in the
present as well human machine delivery
systems and big data management most
recently though he has been taking a
really bold agenda which is to go and
look at the database systems
architecture which you know it's not
exactly young and say that maybe using
data and you know machine learning
techniques we can take a hard look at
this components and see how can the
beery architect
you know how can they be even better
than what it has been traditionally and
I think we are going to hear some of
that today I also wanted to say that he
has had many hours I've mentioned some
of them here's I Triple E did
engineering best paper award in 2013 and
the Sloan fellowship award 2017 and most
recently he is the winner of the 2018
Wildeve early carrier research
contributions over with that Tim thank
you thanks thanks can you all hear me
like in the back as well so get perfect
so what I'm going to talk about it's
actually a paper we published this year
in sigmod called like the case for
learned index structures half of the
talk like if you have seen maybe before
like particularly the Microsoft people
you know it already
however I all said it's some new stuff
with it or multi-dimensional index
indexes for the second half so you can
fall asleep for the first 10 minutes so
the book like we we publish as like not
it's actually went like viral last year
and it all started with a tweet by
Christopher Manning saying that machine
learning just it a grows in one despite
I just want to give you a disclaimer
here upfront me by no means belief that
machine learning is or has eaten the
whole field of algorithms and data
structures however we do believe maybe
it has like it taking a little bite from
it and there's a lot of more interesting
work to be done so why are people so
excited about it the fundamental
building blocks essentially of all
systems in particular to data management
systems are data structure and
algorithms and we have a whole range of
really of these fundamental data
structures from sorting different
sorting algorithms hashmaps different
types of indexes priority queues and so
on all these data structures have been
common that they essentially make no
assumptions about the data so now let me
give you just a very simple example
let's assume that in your database
system you want to store and Kure all
the integers from 900 to 800 million and
you are interested in range crease for
them you are looking into like okay
scanning for example all the integers
from 100 to something and they're
calling records it's a very simple
example
in this particular case probably nobody
here would actually use a b-tree for it
right because it's just like there's you
know that has all the integers in that
range
instead what you could do is heavens the
earth for an index structure just like
the lookup key itself as an offset so
what you do is just like look up into
your data store the lookup key - 900
which gives you the offset and you can
immediately start reading and because
you know something about the data
distribution so now assume that you
store all even integer numbers from 9
heart rate and a million and the same
trick still works right you take 3 look
up key minus 100 divided by 2 which
gives you again the offset and you can
look at them immediately up so what we
did here is essentially like we had to
be to be before me just like a log n
lookup time alright so you need to
traverse this and now transform that to
something which is essentially over this
still holds to true for other data
distributions as long as you know the
empirical data distribution and can
compactly represent it
so the key insight is that if we take
this like deck box of the data and now
just like maybe the white box by saying
like okay if you know something about
your empirical data distribution about
the data you store you can put much much
better data structures for them and in
some cases even transform the compare
complexity class now obviously it's not
like efficient to build one system from
scratch for every single use case you
have all right this is not economical
but this is exactly where machine
learning comes then because it provides
us the toolbox to learn these types of
models and then take afterwards
advantage of them so here I will use B
trees as the main example and just for
simplicity right now I assume that we
have an in-memory immutable B tree with
no inserts and no paging just like for
simplification I will talk about inserts
and paging later on so if you think what
a b-tree actually does is like given a
key the B tree finds you the position
inside a sorted array
normally we page the sorted array
meaning that we put it in two different
pages and then for example you only
index the first key in
the page just for like efficiency
reasons that the b-tree doesn't blow
entirely up and so in that sense but the
bee tree does given a key it finds me
the page and then I need to search
inside the page to find the extra key so
it's already an approximate data
structure because given the key you get
the position inside the sorted array and
then you have to search inside the page
size right so it's a guarantee that you
will find out there in that sense I can
actually replace the bee tree there's a
model as long as I have a key and the
model predicts me the position where
this key might be in the inside the
sorted array I'm good now the question
is just like the first okay how do I
still get to guarantee that I can still
find my key inside the sorted array
where is it like so in the previous case
the page defined like the minimax error
where to find the key first of all it's
actually surprisingly simple so let's
assume I have an monotonically
increasing model what that means is just
like I can run every key through the
model and then look on how fighters off
and simply remember the maximum over and
under prediction which gives me a strong
error bound in the end it turns out we
don't even need that because given that
the whole thing is sorted anyway I get a
prediction and then I can do something
like exponential search to find actually
the key right in place wherever it is
without needing to search everything so
I can get the bound and then like with
the bound I would do binary search if I
don't have the bound I could do
something like exponential starts so
turns out like what we're actually doing
here is the index is like modeling the
CDF of the data so given a key it finds
me the position inside the sorted array
there's just nothing else than trying to
estimate the probability mass of every
key which is equal or less than the key
I'm looking up times the number of keys
I have in total which gives me the
position inside the sorted array this in
fact is interesting because this allows
us to take advantage of this like whole
literature out there on how like CDF's
can be modeled if more interesting is
that a b-tree itself can also be seen as
a model already it's a form of a
regression
three and it's just like a special form
of it which is like a special structure
but it's also a model all right so it's
nothing even but we do right now you can
actually see it's models it's just I'm
just saying you can use other things as
well so what does it mean and that makes
potentially some people here very very
happy that is data based people were
actually the very first to do large
scale machine learning right because we
were the first to do like large Petrie's
which is nothing else when I was just
sort of then building a model so what
might be the potential of using like
other models than the normal regression
trees or B trees and there are a whole
bunch of them first of all they might
lead to smaller indexes if we for
example in the case before if we know we
have all the integers I can build a much
more compact representation of it the
only thing I need is like the offset
maybe an intercept in the slope and I'm
done right so it's much more space
efficient I might get faster lookups I
might get more parallelism and that is
mainly because like in for many models
I'm transforming like the very heavy if
statements B tree needs to traverse into
multiplications and additions I might be
taking be able to take advantage of
hardware accelerators and we heard in
the morning already that there's like a
lot of excitement going on in building
FPGA especially for machine learning
so now by transforming them I might have
an advantage to actually leverage them
also for database systems and there are
also sense of like having cheaper
inserts I will talk about that later
so we tried that out very early on like
after having this like observation in
terms of loss would be built like a tens
of Lamoille
to layout fully connected 32 based
really activated we trained it over 200
million maps of a lock records we wanted
to index the timestamp and essentially
like the role of the integrals give me a
time so give me the position inside the
sorter to write so cache optimize b-tree
for this task roughly takes 250
nanoseconds any guesses how long
tensorflow takes
the first attempt 80,000 so me
successfully made it like almost three
orders of magnitudes a little bit more
slower and it's not very successful the
reason for them are very manifold like
first of all tender flows designed for
very large models not for this like tiny
things which are supposed to run in the
range of nanoseconds the search doesn't
take advantage that we actually get
pretty close by the prediction but like
often our min and Max arrow is very very
large but it's like most of the time we
actually close by so if you binary
search this throws you off and then like
B trees are very very casual fashioned
so if you have a large model you lose
that as well plus like they are great
for overfitting and in this case
overfitting as long as you only have
lookups and no insert is actually a good
thing because there's more you over fit
you better look up your data you have
yeah I'm only addressing the last two
because I need them later on to explain
by how a multi-dimensional indexes work
so to overcome the problem that we have
like a very efficient way to overfit to
something we came up with this structure
which we call the recursive model index
but you you can best think of it just
like a scene like an expert model they
are one model the top one picks another
model which is an expert for a certain
range of the data right so if you have
one model at the top which takes the key
makes a prediction based on the
prediction you pick another model which
knows that area better which might pick
another model right so the nice thing
about that is it can be very very
efficiently implemented right so let's
assume I have a top model F 0 ever moral
models on stage 2 which is an array of
models right so what I'm actually doing
is just like I execute the first model
which gives me an index position into
the array of models of the second stage
which I then execute which gives me the
final position if I have a two-stage
model if I now for everything don't use
neural nets but let's assume just like
linear regression the whole look up as
you can see here down here takes me two
multiplies two additions and one error
lookup
this is the execution of the index that
read there's like some code necessary
for boundary checks but it turns out you
can also avoid that and you just need to
change the learning a little bit so that
boundary checks are never necessary
furthermore you can in some cases even
replace some of the molds using normal
b-trees right so if you say like okay in
a certain area the normal linear model
or neural net or whatever you are using
everything is fair game doesn't work
very well so just replace that piece of
it using a normal B tree and and you get
like the normal guarantees right
the nice thing of doing that is the
worst-case performance is in the end is
the one of rust like the B tree because
in the worst case just grates to a be
tree
we started out with that it turns out
like it most of our data sets right now
we never use that anymore because the
complexity of mixing different models
normally doesn't pay off it's easier to
just use more models so it doesn't have
to be neural nets the answer is clearly
no you can use whatever fits and this is
essentially also what we are doing right
now we normally use very simple let me
immoral multivariate models in
particular cases we are more complex
data is required sometimes neural nets
but very simple ones the neural Nets
actually the most complicated things are
the activation function because they're
often very expensive to execute on a CPU
so it doesn't work what we did here is
just like we compared to a cache
optimized and read optimized Petri tune
to get the best look at performance and
compared to our launch indexes and what
you see is just like overall we get like
up to a factor of two faster and safe
like up to one order or even more in
main memory we also compared it against
other state of that index structures for
example fast look-up tables fixed size B
trees with interpolation search and here
it plucks the alternatives in regard to
lookup time where the size and the left
lower corner is where you want to be and
you can see that like the learned in
exes is like a dominant solution so what
about like our assumption I did in the
beginning about inserts and paging first
of all inserts might not be such a big
problem in the end so let's assume that
your inserts follow roughly the data
distribution what
have learned in that sense you don't
need to rebalance the model right you
don't need to change it you can just
reuse the model make space wherever you
want to insert something this is
particular easy to see if you have
mostly like inserts let's assume you
have time stands for IOT devices
the time since normally increase they
might increase was the same patterns
what you have observed in the past so
the model simply generalizes there's a
b-tree you have to rebalance all the
time of course the big question becomes
if it doesn't follow exactly the data
distribution how do you still rebalance
but there is something like robust
machine learning which takes care of
that so they are like new approaches now
the question second question is like
paging often what we have is just like
we want to page the do particular if
it's on disk here one simple solution is
actually that you use the model itself
to determine the pages so normally a
b-tree it takes what goes into a page
right like if you have a index organized
table the index tells you what you
should put on the page you can do the
same thing here and then you get around
most of the problems you would have
otherwise as paging so we started with
b-trees but it turned out like this same
idea also applies to many many other
data structures from drawing sorta
engagement bloom filters priority queues
for example one of my colleagues
mammoths is working on new like long
scheduling algorithms for data analytics
there's work on cache policies by Google
we are looking into query optimization
what we can do there there's a whole
range where you can apply very similar
ideas most of the time it's all about
learning the CDF of your data and taking
advantage of that so here I just want to
mention something out which is
multi-dimensional indexes so our big
hope when we started that actually was
not to get like more efficient index
structures for signal I mentioned ours
hope was always like okay in the moment
we will call multi-dimensional we
assumed we would see the bigger benefits
there because was machine learning in
general or like most of the mods are
really really good and it's just like
capturing all the complex relationships
made a half right so machine learning
was just like predefined to say like
okay it should perform very well on
multi-dimensional data
the biggest problem we faced in the
beginning is just like that
unfortunately even if we learn all these
complex correlations in the end there's
only one order on disk which is one
dimensional of course you can see like
this gamma complex but like in the end
you have like one order for scanning and
this is like a big fundamental
limitations on how you deal with it
because at some point doesn't matter how
you do it you need to transform what you
have in the multi dimensional space to
warn order on disk and this is like in
the end word medicine or order you have
in my memory so how can you do that so
let's assume these are like the
different data points you have
let's assume like you have this is maybe
some order data you have the order
amount and order zip code and those are
like two dimensions you make queries for
one approach you could say like okay if
the the two attributes are equally
important to you you project them just
through the middle this is like you can
see as a form of PCA because we give
each the equal weight and then you have
one projection to a one dimensional
space and this is like the sorting order
you use on disk and you can immediately
see in some cases this is like fine and
others this will not work very well
right for example if you know that most
of the the queries you do for the order
amount and not for the order zip code
the best thing you can actually do is
the order you all your data in record
regarding the order amount and this
regards the zip code for that if you
move to look up for zip codes you would
do the opposite thank you or everything
for zip code but you ignore the order
amount right so there is a traitor from
how you actually serialize the data on
how you lay it out so the interesting
thing is we found that you can actually
even mix them for example you can say
like okay I project down to zip code
then I built like larger blocks and
though within a block maybe I want to
use a different projection in this case
order amount so I first split up into
zip codes and then I project down to or
amount so I have like every block is now
ordered within regarding to the order
amount and again I can trade them off on
how they depend and what's best highly
depends on your workload right so if you
never touch the zip code you should
probably not order for them
because it doesn't provide you any
benefit in this led to our like final
design right now what we have for multi
dimension indexes is we start out with
the data points we have we have a first
model which is called a projector which
based on the block load projects it into
our order we have later on on disk what
we do there is like exactly the trick I
showed you before we allow columns on
how we split it down to this in these
like blocks so we start with a root node
which triggers out to general direction
of the data depending on like and what
crews are most common then it projects
everything to this dimension and then we
repeat the process and make directions
projections for all the different blocks
separately again often they're
orthogonal to each other just because on
how the data is layout so we get like
for example these projections down here
that you can see now like this in every
block we have actually a different order
of them and they have will like morals
of moles again to define or find it like
some like point in that space later on
on the disk also interesting this can be
recursed so you can make it as deep as
you want and this model itself here is
the same data structure as what I showed
you before for I am I this is like again
this like expert model on the top which
picks another experts which organizes us
differently this if you have only linear
models can be executed again for
two-stage models and two multiplies two
additions in one area lookup so it's
extremely fast however if you have the
projector it still doesn't give us now
like where to find something on in a
dense array because like still there
might be space in between so what we do
in order to get the dense array is
nothing else and what we had before it's
just like built a locator again using an
RMI model and so like me this is like
essentially if you have everything in
the fundamental space and now we built
like the the same beech tree model what
we had before
all right so this is pretty new but some
very very initial like performance
number shows was like pretty promising
so for 1 million data points right now
we get like roughly 200 nanoseconds
lookups for point trace this is like a
speed-up of like 2 to 10
over the artery's depending on how you
configure it well you have like an
order-of-magnitude space savings of
course there's like more to come we need
more workloads and this is like
essentially this lookup here's without
considering the the dock load itself yet
because we haven't done that even so
it's just assumes everything is
uniformly likely which is actually the
worst case scenario fuss also
interesting to notice this data
structure in contrast to an artery
doesn't increase with the numbers of
dimensions you have instead it should
increase with the rank of the data so if
you have like for example at the same
attribute again just a full duplicate it
wouldn't make any change to our layout
or the model complexity so for future
work there's much more to be done we are
heavily looking into sorting and joining
so essentially what we want to figure
out is just like can we not improve
every single component of a database
system using models and how would that
look like if you put in the end
everything together and the core insight
is that if you have a model an efficient
model about your data distribution how
would you actually build your data
structure our grows and with that you
have an Oracle which tells you okay the
probability mass given for ki in your
data set probably this this Oracle you
would design many of the algorithms and
data structures you have in a very very
different way the other thing is just
like it's all about continuous functions
so if you compare that now for example
to all of preserving hashing perfect
hashing local sensitive hashing all the
different variants you have like
normally they don't take advantage of
like the fact that you can this
continuous functions much much better
approximate the rough position so it's
like a form of interpolation search but
often them is regression or you can like
more and more complex shapes if you do
that you have like data structures which
learn automatically adapt to the data
you have and they're potentially run on
GPUs of GPUs or FPGA is whatever is you
are your preferred machine learning
platform and in some cases can even
lower the complexity class for storage
as well as lookup time
for example if you saw that in the case
of the data area look up and I can also
show you similar things for the
multi-dimensional cases now as well
however just a warning ahead this is not
an almighty solution right there of
course like datasets where students
traditional b-tree might be better it's
like a lot to be done but it's like I
think a very exciting direction I'm also
very happy to announce that we are like
starting decel for data systems for our
lab at MIT and that Microsoft is like
one of our major sponsors for it it
involves like half systems people have
ml people from both sides and the key
questions we are investigating is like
how we can use machine learning for
systems or build systems for machine
learning is that I think I more or less
in time would like to conclude so what I
showed you it's like a new approach for
indexing I think it's a framework to
rethink many existing data structures
and algorithms and a certain kind of
conditions that might change the
complexity class for particular instance
of the data it's always important to say
and the idea might have implications
within and outside database systems
thank you any questions
oh there's a question Peter
peter has just just they'll give you a
microphone I can also repeat it it's
fine
thank you hi so uh can can you explain a
little bit about what it looks like when
you're actually learning these these
models versus the process of building a
b-tree so if you're you know if you're
doing dynamically maintaining these
things on the fly you know it's it's a
little unclear from your talk you know
kind of what it looks like blob of data
what do you do right so like the like to
create an index so what I mainly talk to
you about what's only read-only data so
the the simplest thing is just like you
sort your data and then if you use for
example a two-stage linear model the top
model you can train in one pass over the
data actually you don't even need to
fool data you can skip pieces of it
because the sample is often more than
enough right so it's just like one pass
over it because it's a closed form
there's no gradient descent or anything
then what you use is like you use the
top model go all the data points you
have put every data point into the
bucket for what expert it belongs and
one level down this is our greedy
training approach and then you for every
bucket you repeat the process so like
you go over the data as many stages you
have right so if you have to stitch
models you have to passes over the data
if you have those three stage model
three passes over the data and so on it
goes extremely fast I mean like a b-tree
you can build in one pass over the data
if everything is solid but like it's you
know like the first one doesn't they can
work on a sample insert there's another
paper by casting and some of my
collaborators brown we have you look
into on how we can do inserts more
efficiently the easiest way what you do
is just like you have a delta index
mines instead of doing the inserts every
single time retraining them all you put
them in a delta and then at some point
you figure out if it's most by
retraining or merging over
oh there's a question back there gent
and then there's Jen has a question
so you're benching that you would like
to know the CDF's of the single column
distributions in advance and isn't that
already given to you by the histograms
that most database systems already
maintain for these columns so I didn't
see you talking about the interaction
between histograms and the machine
learning process right so histograms are
in the end still very coarse-grained so
the question is just like okay if you
would create a histogram with the
granularity you have we need for
actually looking the data up then it's a
question okay how do you browse the
histogram itself and if you solve that
problem actually what you get is a
b-tree and so I can show that you can
transform one into the other and because
you need like the lookup structures all
right so histograms himself don't help
you that much
there is something like look-up tables
which is like the thing in between but
like I had numbers for them they also
don't help you that much the interesting
thing is now let's assume I built my
better model for it like let's say that
I my model to stage for the index I can
use the same model as my histogram and
so instead like instead of having
histogram which I cannot use as an index
I can use as my indexes as a histogram
and the performance penalty is almost
not existing even better I can use the
same histograms also to plug them into
my curry optimizer I can do sorting with
them essentially if I have one CDF model
I can use the same model in many many
different places of my database system
from joining sorting index saying query
optimization and other things
the key challenge though there is it's
very simple for one dimension it's a
little bit harder for multiple
dimensions so then there's just a
conditional probabilities and so on what
you do that so did it work yes so back
to a Peters question how about other
issues such as logging logging
compression and civilization logging
locking compression and serialization
okay let me stop
impression because it's the best story
so let's assume that your index given
the key is gives you the position where
to find that key let's assume my model
is in a very book that I can ask the
reverse question given a position tell
me what keys most likely there if my
model would be perfect
I don't need my keys anymore it
compresses my data essentially alright
because given a position I know which
key I expect there why should I store
the keys anymore if the model is not
perfect what I can do is like a delta
compress against the expected key at
that position so again the moral becomes
my compression technique so this
compression locking it's like this a big
question about on how you actually make
like B trees just like serializable and
everything is everything else
arias it's just like the paper everybody
hates and still everybody uses but it's
just like it's in this way like because
you deal with the inserts in a different
vein or approximate fashion anyway my
assumption is that like many of this
complexity of locking is not actually
needed I think Microsoft is heavily
looking into that array I heard so they
are very very excited about that
logging is like I'm like transaction
processing and logging is still
something you will need because you want
the utilizability guarantees and be
everything consistence I adopted machine
learning at least I cannot think of an
easy way right now to improve that well
with that beam thanks very much for an
exciting talk so thanks
[Applause]
our last speaker for this session is
Matilde haria and he's a faculty member
at Stanford University and previously he
was at MIT a faculty during his PhD as
you know he started the Apache spark
computing engine as well as worked on a
number of open-source projects such as
missiles Apaches Burke turned into a
company that he landed a founding called
data breaks 4 which is the chief
technologist as well he has had a number
of hours
ACM doctoral dissertation award the
VMware Systems research award and
Daytona gray sought world-record more
recently has been working on asking the
question to have machine learning and
the data scientist be well supported on
a data analytic platform what needs to
happen what are the gaps and he's going
to talk about that today so after having
finished the two talks looking at how ml
or the reading techniques could help the
database internals they're going to
shift care and listen to him to see what
we need to do to make sure in addition
to the querying and the other things
data analytic systems give what you have
to do special to make it easy for the
data scientist Marty yes all right
thanks argit let me know if you can't
hear me okay so yeah cirrage it said I'm
going to talk about infrastructure for
usable machine learning and I'll
actually start by talking about a bunch
of research that we're doing in a lab on
this at Stanford called dawn Microsoft
is one of the generous sponsors of dawn
so we appreciate that and then I'll also
briefly put on my industry hat and talk
about a type of system that basically
hundreds of organizations are building
in industry and that there isn't a lot
of research about so I think it's
something that we should look at as
researchers as well although I am
looking at it in industry so it's really
the golden age of machine learning
they're incredible advances in image
recognition natural language planning
yada yada yada it's a great story and
there have starting to have society
skill impact every enjoyed that but if
you look at a little bit more carefully
statement comes with a caveat so it's
the Golden Age of machine learning for
the best funded best trained engineering
teams if you are a company you know with
tens of thousands of engineers it's
awesome you're happy you can do it but
it's still very difficult for anyone
else to actually use machine learning
and have any kind of real-world impact
so building machine learning products is
still very difficult and very expensive
all the major successes the things that
actually make it into products that make
a difference things like you know Siri
or Alexa or autopilot require hundreds
to thousands of engineer's just working
on them continuously to build and
maintain those systems and the
interesting thing if you look at is you
know what are those engineers doing are
they're all sitting around a whiteboard
you know doing integrals and like
drawing neural networks and stuff
they're actually not doing that they're
not really doing you know the stuff you
learn in a machine learning class most
of the stuff they're doing that's really
expensive is data preparation Quality
Assurance debugging and production
ization so that's what is really needed
to defeat these systems and it's not
modeling and so just a domain expert you
know in a specific area can't easily
build machine learning products so if
you look at it from a research
perspective it's actually a really
interesting thing to look at because it
means that the problems that people have
in production you know any say
enterprise user you talk with you ask
hey are you using machine learning
what's hard the problems that they face
are not the problems that machine
learning researchers primarily work on
those researchers work on settings where
you already have a data set you already
have a target metric that everyone
agrees is the right one to optimize and
you don't even care about production
izing the model you just care about like
coming up with a training method and
that is not what anyone actually using
this stuff for real has to do so is this
really a big mismatch where you know as
a systems or data management researcher
you can go in and and have an impact
we're not the only ones to say this and
another example of you know paper that
says this is actually this one from
Google where they talk about you know
what's involved in building these
systems and they say
only a fraction of the real world ml
systems are the ML code all this other
stuff around that is what takes a lot of
time is expensive and is hard to do so
in the Stanford done project it's a it's
a it's a project with the other PI's
peter baelish chris a kunde and myself
we're looking at specifically this
problem all this stuff needed around the
machine learning algorithms to build
production applications to the enable
domain experts to build them and we want
to make it easy to build them without
the PhD and machine learning but also
importantly without being an expert in
systems and data management and hardware
to get all that other infrastructure
around that to work so in this talk I'm
gonna talk about a few pieces of what
we're building and done just to give you
examples I won't have time to go into a
lot of detail but just what are these
problems you know at the outside of
traditional machine learning and then
I'll also talk as I said about some
stuff happening in industry in this
space so first thing I'll talk about so
Don we were building the software spec
that stack that spans all these phases
from data acquisition to production and
the first thing I'll talk about to give
you a sense of like you know what these
problems can look like is actually one
of quiz race projects called snorkle
which is at the data acquisition phase
and this is about acquiring or using
training data so training data is
obviously the key to machine learning
and the places where it's been most
successful are the places where it's
very easy and cheap to obtain
high-volume training data so you know
image search for images that occur on
the internet not not you know for things
like medical images there's so much data
you can you can look at it you can build
really good models speech people are
talking all the time I'm talking right
now you can record me you can you know
it could probably build a model of what
I'm gonna say games you know just play
some video games against yourself
that's good you'll get lots of data on
the other hand a lot of the business
applications that actually matter are
ones were getting labeled data
especially is quite expensive so you
know medical images you can't just
google them and see lots of x-rays and
start learning from those because you
know there might not even be that many
patients that have like a certain
disease
document understanding you know you need
like say a lawyer to sit down and like
read a piece of text and tell you you
know what the law would interpret it
like and that person's gonna cost you
thousands of dollars per hour you can't
just get people to you know click on
things for one cent an hour and so on so
the question in the snorkel project is
how can we leverage data that's
expensive for humans to label at scale
and this labeling can easily be you know
ninety percent of the cost in many
business applications of machine
learning so Christmas project snorkel
basically looks at a different interface
for labeling which is which is called
labeling functions so instead of asking
humans to just give you labels you know
look at all these examples and give me a
zero or one for each one based on your
expertise as a human this project
snorkel asked them to provide labeling
functions which are short programs you
know from a computer science standpoint
that that can can give you a guess at a
label but they may not always be
accurate so for example one thing you
could do is you could sit down with say
medical doctors and you know show them
some notes about patients and instead of
asking for each one like you know is it
this disease or not you can tell you can
ask them hey what do you look for that
lets you think that this is heart
disease and then you can turn that into
a little Python function like searching
for a red X or something like that and
then snorkel is a training system that
can take a bunch of these functions and
it simultaneously learns you know when
each one is right and wrong how noisy it
is and the target model for the data so
it can incorporate this uncertainty from
these functions but the benefit of this
interface is just by sitting down and
coding a bunch of these functions after
you interview a domain expert you can
then apply them to millions of unlabeled
examples and documents so for example
Chris's groups are done with with
researchers in the medical school at
Stanford who are doing these projects to
automatically understand documents or
case notes or things like that and in
just four hours of writing stuff with
them they would match basically months
or years of hand labeling these poor
grad students in
feels like part of their PhD is sitting
down for two years to label documents
you know to build an automatic system
for understanding them so that's that's
kind of the impact obviously saves a lot
of time and money and across a variety
of datasets
snorkle can match basically systems that
have been trained on label data just by
using a bunch of these functions and
millions of examples that were not
labeled by humans at all before so it's
a this is a very brief overview Chris
actually has a whole research program
around this called data programming
which is about automatically preparing
training data as a kind of a fourth
class concept and it's also all open
source so you can find out about it
online but this is an example of you
know type of problem that real users of
machine learning will face as another
example of sort of a point problem I'll
talk about production and in particular
serving and I'll talk about this project
no scope which is joint project between
myself and Peter Bayliss so you know
machine learning models are very
accurate especially the new deep
learning ones the the in in many ways in
many cases the larger the models are the
more accurate they are and so people
want to deploy them but many times the
actual inference process is the
bottleneck and it's going to be the most
expensive part and this is why you see
projects like brain wave and so on that
try to accelerate that inference so in
this project we looked at using CNN's to
do quais on video something a lot of
people want to do CNN's are really good
at recognizing and labeling objects now
but the problem is these really good
CNN's you know they can they they're
also expensive so they can pass this you
know one video stream in real time on a
you know like on a large you know server
class GPU that's what's considered a
real-time inference in the computer
vision community and of course if you
have many say millions of hours of video
or lots of video streams you don't want
to stand up you know huge GPU cluster to
monitor and even for a modest-sized
building this would cost you millions of
dollars so in this project no score
we look at how can you get you know
orders of magnitude faster video quays
with a minimal loss in accuracy given
these kind of black boxy and end models
that you know are really accurate but
expensive so we use a bunch of
techniques to do this but one of the key
techniques is model specialization so
basically we're given this model that's
good at recognizing things you don't
really you don't necessarily need to
know what it does internally and we're
also given a Quay like for example I
just want to count cars that are driving
by my building and we're also given a
bunch of data to run this way on which
is you know the specific video frames
from the camera outside my building so
what we do with this is we use this big
model we label a few samples from the
data with it and we use it to train a
much smaller specialized model and this
model is specialized to microwave it
doesn't need to recognize you know
pandas or motorcycles or things like
that it just needs to recognize cars
it's also specialized to my data
distribution for example maybe my camera
is looking down at the street so I don't
need to worry about cars that I flipped
upside down and things like that so
these are reasons why from a machine
learning standpoint you can have a
smaller capacity model that is pretty
accurate for this particular Quay and
the other cool thing about this this
model is we can train it to also output
a confidence score so when it's not sure
about the label of a frame we can always
call the original model and it turns out
that by tuning basically the size of
this model and and the confidence
thresholds you can actually capture most
of the accuracy of the big model and
still save you know 99% of the
invitations to it so we also design a
cost-based optimizer that can can solve
this problem of how you know exactly
which specialized model to use and which
thresholds when basically the results
from this are that you know depending on
your accuracy target you can get large
speed ups off in an order of magnitude
or more over you know over these
original models and still capture a lot
of the accuracy so we evaluated seven
streams and this first paper we had on
it and basically
you know in in this was the best one
where you could go thousands of times
faster and keep 95% of the accuracy even
and the worst times you could go about
an order of magnitude faster so it's a
pretty powerful technique to use for
inference and it's it's easy to apply
probably beyond video as well and just
as a example of extending this further
an ongoing work which is on archive
we're also extending this to more
complex sequel like ways where we see a
query and we use a mix of techniques
including model specialization and
approximate query processing to design a
very fast inference pipeline for that
query that meets a certain target
accuracy so you can read about that as
well to see how you can combine these
different things it's there's a little
bit more than just model specialization
in that so that's an example on the
infant side of the kind of problems that
are needed to actually use these models
in production the next step I'll talk
about and kind of the final dawn example
I'll talk about is for software
development and the approach we have
several projects looking at here is
designing end-to-end compiler is that
let let you know sort of productivity
programmers get excellent performance
and have basically built a production
grade application so I'll talk about
specifically one of my projects here
which is called weld so if you look at
the you know the data science machine
learning space there are a ton of
different processing steps you want to
do with data and there's a huge
ecosystem of libraries and to be
productive and also you want to
experiment really quickly so programmer
productivity is super important and the
main technique we have for programmer
productivity in general is composition
it's the only way that we've made it
more efficient to develop software so ml
app developers will compose functions
from all these high-level libraries you
know thousands of Python packages are
packages SPARC packages etc and so for
example you might use something like
pandas and Python to clean up some data
you might use numpy to do some
operations on it to normalize it and
then you might use a machine learning
library like cycad lord
and so you'll be composing these
functions now the interesting thing
about this is that it creates kind of an
important problem for optimization which
is even though each individual function
you call might be highly optimized and
they often are you know these numerical
routines are very carefully tuned your
end-to-end pipeline could be extremely
inefficient and that's bad it means that
you know your training will be slow and
then your production serving will be
slow and in many companies actually the
data scientists have to throw their code
over a fence to a production software
engineering team that rewrites it to
make it efficient and that's obviously
not not going to be cheaper and it's not
something we want to do so the the one
reason this happens is just because the
traditional interface for composing
these libraries doesn't give you a lot
of room to optimize in particular most
libraries have these interfaces written
in terms of function calls that's the
abstraction and every programming
language and you know to write a library
that operates on big data you give your
function a pointer to data that's
sitting somewhere in memory that's
usually how you pass things to so this
is an example of a bunch of functions
I'm calling in Python I'm gonna parse
and and then filter some data and then
compute an average and then this is what
actually happens so these functions in
in pandas and numpy are actually all
weighted and see they're well optimized
but what's really going to happen is I'm
gonna call each one separately and scan
through the data out of memory and then
write it back each time I go through it
so for example parse CSV the interface
is I give you a pointer to the input
string and I give you a pointer to an
output buffer and you parse it so has to
do basically two scans through the data
then drop in a again the interfaces I
give you an array you give me a new
array it's doing two scans to the data
again and finally in the mean I'm gonna
do a single array of course memory
access time dominates especially for a
big data so in you know in a real
application this can lead to a
significant slowdown and we actually
measure it in just sort of example
workloads and popular frameworks
even though each operator is optimized
they use dozens of operators and you get
these very large overheads from just
data movement across them so in the
world project at Stanford what we're
doing is we're basically designing a
common intermediate representation and a
common runtime for data analytics
libraries similar to you know like a
language virtual machine but designed
for data parallel code and the idea is
these libraries submit the computation
they want to do - you know - this on
time engine it lazily collects the
computation from different libraries and
then it can optimize it for different
backends and this can lead to
significant speed ups as well so this is
an example of a pandas and numpy
pipeline it's combining operators that
are all written in C but if you turn on
weld you get around the 10x speed up on
one thread if you turn on cross library
optimization in world you get another
factor of 3 and then welds intermediate
language is actually it's a functional
language that's data parallel so it's
it's trivial to safely parallelize it so
you can also turn on multi-threading
underneath these existing libraries and
get a large speed-up we have a few
papers on the system and also on how we
optimize underneath it for real
workloads and then again so just just to
give you a sense of some ongoing work
this this shows that ok optimizing
across libraries is useful and it gives
you know we try to make this as
lightweight as possible to give users a
really clean and simple intermediate
language they can write stuff in but
it's a bunch of work for them to
instrument and modify all these
libraries to use it so actually in this
ongoing work we're doing world without
world we have abstraction called split
ability annotations and this is a way to
enable most of the optimizations that
world gives you on unmodified blackbox
functions we don't even need the source
code of your function so for example in
MK l the Intel math kernal library there
are all these hand optimized routines
for linear algebra one of them is
actually adding a bunch of vectors and
they're really fast and if my program
just need a tad to
this would be awesome but my program
actually needs to do hundreds of linear
algebra operations and these functions
you know are designed to take the whole
thing at once so it's not that good so
what we can do and you know this might
be my program it's adding lots of
vectors together what we can do is for
ability annotations as we add an
annotation to each function that says
how we can split up the data to call the
function on little chunks of it this is
very similar to vectorize sort of
execution in in databases with like
little batches it's just adding that
annotation to say how we can split this
up in this case it means these are
arrays that we're adding element wise so
you can split them any way you want into
little chunks as long as the chunks have
the same shape across them so we have
this type system here for that going to
express more complicated ways of
splitting and once you do that you can
actually get these significant speed ups
basically from pipelining underneath
these functions so in this case even
though mkl itself is multi-threaded it's
well optimized and so on
we got in this case a factor of eight
speed-up in in in various this is
actually an in this simple workload but
also in a bunch of real workloads by
pipelining the execution of them
essentially and it's pretty cool because
we never had to change the code of mko
so this is still work in progress but
the the interesting result from this is
it can often get competitive performance
with systems like weld or xla or other
compiler based systems without rewriting
these libraries so it's a super
lightweight way to add stuff to an
existing library so that's an example of
making programmers more productive okay
and then the final bit I'll talk about
now putting on my industry hat for a bit
is this new type of system for machine
learning at industrial scale which is a
machine learning platforms and what's
really interesting about this is
basically I think hundreds of companies
are building these platforms it's a real
need they're actually engineering teams
building these things but there's not a
lot of research about it and I think
it's an important system to know about
if you if you want to
look at research in this field there's
also a lot of unknowns and ways to
innovate here so basically the question
here is if you believe machine learning
will be a key part of future products
what should be the software development
process for it so we see this in a lot
of the companies that I talk with for
example at data breaks as well as at
Stanford they said ok we had one or two
projects that were successful with
machine learning but they took a lot of
time and you know they were expensive to
do how can I have hundreds of teams in
my company using machine learning how
can I make it you know not just a
one-off like sort of experiment but
something that every team can reliably
use and today unfortunately just machine
learning out of the box is the
development for it is very ad hoc so
there are a few problems that make this
difficult so one problem is just
tracking experiments so and when you do
machine learning you're gonna be running
many variations of your code I'm sure in
the previous two talks there were many
versions of the models that didn't work
and then finally you saw the ones that
did work and today you know there's no
first class support for this in the
system's you do in software development
in general you have a linear you know
set of commits you never have like
hundreds of branches that you need to
track and compare with each other so
every data scientist has their own way
of managing experiments it's really
important to reproduce the results and
it's also very difficult because you
have dependencies on datasets on code on
parameters all over the place and again
there's no automatic way to capture them
and it's also difficult to share and
manage models actually for some
companies just tracking which model is
deployed where did it come from is is is
a non-trivial problem because there
could be you know thousands of models so
we need sort of the equivalent of
software development platforms if you
think of something like building a web
application or mobile application
there's so much infrastructure around
testing ID ease load balancers you know
quality assurance that is just they're
out of the box you don't need to worry
about it
but again machine learning is different
because of the wide range of parameters
and experiments
so many companies are actually building
a new class of system to do this that
I'm just gonna name ml platforms because
that's what they named them some of the
more prominent examples that people you
know what lock posts about our at the
large web companies so Facebook FB
Lerner uber Michelangelo Google T FX but
there are also many of these at smaller
companies and also you know even when I
talk to individual machine learning grad
students or researchers they say oh yeah
I have like a Python library that tries
to record experiments for me that's what
they're doing so these platforms the way
these usually work is there's an
engineering team that says ok here are
you know the 10 algorithms that you can
use for machine learning and if you use
one of these 10 we will handle
deployment we'll handle running
experiments tuning parameters and so on
so we'll handle the whole lifecycle so
it's good because they standardized the
lifecycle you know that if you work
within this platform it will remember
what you did and let you deploy it and
let you roll back and stuff but just
having everyone build their own is also
a disadvantageous first of all they each
limited to whatever frameworks or
algorithms that company decided to
support and engineers after add a new
one and second they're also tied to this
internal infrastructure so you can't
really share these things across across
companies so one of the projects that
I'm working on at data breaks is
actually an open source open interface
machine learning platform that we
launched back in June this year it's
called ml flow and I'll just give you a
sense of what it can do but you know you
can read about this and the other ones
online just to give you a sense of the
problems so one of the things that it
does is so by open interface I mean that
it's it's designed to work with you know
whatever infrastructure you have and
whatever algorithm as opposed to like
here I can algorithms that we support so
one of the things that does is it lets
you package reproducible projects so
basically you can you know you can you
can you can declare what dependencies
what environment your machine learning
code needs in order to run and you can
also declare parameter is that other
people from outside can use to call it
without having to
the details and then in your code you
you use these parameters and and you
know you do your work so that means you
can package your project and run it
again and get the same result later
second component that has his experiment
tracking so in your code you basically
use this REST API to log information
like here are my parameters here are my
metrics here is the model I built
there's also a way of representing a
model and then ml flow basically builds
a giant database of all the experiments
that have been on for a specific goal
and you can go back and rerun a specific
one or compare them or pull out the
models and do something with them and
then the third part is handled is
deployment which is you know once I've
got a model it actually represents
models as basically a function very
similar to a service function and we can
then deploy the same model to many
different inference tools such as batch
and streaming inference so it's you know
basically it's a it's a pretty simple
kind of workflow system but it's also
something that has a bunch of
interesting data management and systems
challenges how exactly should I
represent projects and dependencies how
should I represent the experiments how
should I equate them you know I can
imagine queries like I had a thousand
different versions of our models and I
have a new data point and I want to know
which one does best on them so there are
a lot of interesting problems to look at
within this space and if you want to
read about this or the other ones it's
just it I think it's an interesting
thing to look at because again people
are actually building these like
hundreds of companies have independently
decided that they need to build a
platform but I don't really see you know
when I look at a database class or
something like that I don't actually see
anyone talking about this class of
system and there's probably a lot that
can be done to to make these things
better so many open questions left in
designing these platforms okay so that
was kind of my brief foray into what's
happening in industry so basically to
conclude the limiting factors of machine
learning adoption are the development
and production ization tools for many
users many real users especially the
ones with really high impact
you know business use cases and they're
not the training algorithms and I think
this is a really great opportunity for
researchers including data management
researchers because a lot of it is a
data problem and they're very unexplored
you can follow the research we're doing
on dawn in our blog and I'm also happy
to chat with anyone about problems in
this space Thanks so of course we are
running late but let's ask if you have
any questions for Marte
let's take a few hi yeah thank you for
the talk I love everything they did yep
I have lots of questions but but they in
the ml platform side of things right I
think especially as we start applying
this to to optimize systems becomes
particularly problematic right because
all of a sudden sequel server stopped
running something somewhere happened and
now I think that beyond what you're
describing there seems to be missing
sort of a the equivalent of a software
engineering practice right yeah you have
to engineering we have like fine bugs
and you know code reviews and all sorts
of practices that kind of protect us
from the worst mistake and specialize
our understanding of what the system is
supposed to do do you have any ideas
yeah I tracking there the experiments
like yeah that's a great question yeah
that's that's an awesome question and
yeah I think it is missing and people
are trying to come up with best
practices so just as an example so these
are some of the things you want to
enable with ml flow is to tell people
hey if you follow this process like
write your code in a project submitted
this way you know pull out the model
this way you'll get the following
benefits but so here are some examples
of thing I've seen so one thing I've
seen at one large company is they
actually have leaderboards for common
tasks so you know let's say you're
building a better language model or a
better image classifier there's a single
leaderboard in the organization where
you can see what this you know how
others have done over time you can
submit yours and you can compare it and
that's a way that you know many people
can work on
and you can kind of see how it's doing
there's a lot of interesting stuff with
testing is my model doing worse than
like say a naive linear model is my data
drifting in some way are my predictions
drifting is the distribution of the
features I see and production are
different for example a common thing is
actually you have a bug where like you
didn't load one of your features into
training or it didn't get transformed
the same way so that's another practice
the other one that is actually hard to
talk about but is is actually even
defining the metric you want to change
and making it easy to swap metric so
that's one of the things that we want to
do in ml flow is if you trained a bunch
of models already and now you want to
change the evaluation metric how can we
easily let you switch that and basically
add a column to that table and compare
them on the new metric yeah other
questions so I think you know we're kind
of don't have the time that we have set
for the panel but this is related to
Carla's question and I would ask both
you Andy and Tim to comment on it if you
have any thoughts on it this is really
the software engineering question but
sometime like for example the kind of
work and ian and team are pursuing
there's always this like old-fashioned
database assistants people the fear that
something will go wrong in a robustness
sense you know that yeah it's kind of an
average case is great but suddenly we
are going to be exposed to a variance
and and this is possible for any system
but typically in a distributed system or
a database system there are guardrails
that you know that you'll trip that
fuels and we basically say okay you know
things are not going well right of
course you don't have to trip the fuse
all the time and have some discipline
around it but is this manageable in the
world that we are sort of entering and
this is also true when we are building
such a flow and so on is is there any
support we get from the system kind of
for understanding this or experimenting
with it at last scale so you know this
is sort of the only question that I
would like all three of you to sort of
comment on it briefly fair any thoughts
right
maybe you can go first yes right here at
the pole yeah so the question is how to
have guardrails for machine learning or
kind of guaranteed we have yeah I think
it's it's a good question I think so far
I've just seen people do
application-specific stuff but basically
I think that the most important things
I've seen are having a fallback that is
you know maybe it's it gives you lower
quality results but it's it's a bus then
you can predict stuff about it and then
also having some kind of monitoring that
tells you if things are going haywire
but the way you do that can be different
in each system it's yeah I I don't think
I understand the fact that we can sort
of go to a safer alternate but to detect
when we should do that yeah is is
sometime the most kind of challenging
part right so yeah it can be I think
again partly just data drift is the
easiest of these things to capture even
that is not super easy but like saying
hey I'm my predictions look super
different or my input data look super
different yeah yeah just in case it in
here Carla Carla's point was just having
a very Steph function like alternative
to fall back on it's probably not
desirable for the system to have some
ways to do it gracefully to the extent
possible right team and and if you have
thoughts come up here will enable the
microphones unless you have given it up
and that will allow you to speak here
are you guys still tied up I don't know
yes I'm still hooked up
can you turn this folks all both on sure
okay so the only thing I would add from
Matea he's right it's like you have to
have a clear objective function to
determine when something's are going bad
the only thing I would add is that you
know the exploitation first exploration
I think being mind having the algorithms
be mindful of what is expected at you at
a given time of day or week
month so that way if it's at nighttime
when your demand is low you can be more
aggressive about trying different things
but during the day when you have you
know SLA is you have to meet for
transactions or your queries then you
want to be bit more conservative and not
try something crazy maybe just not do
any tuning at all right so like so my
perspective is a little bit different
because we mainly want to use machine
learning for like improving the systems
which is a different domain than if I
want to build a model for detecting
images and I think like for example for
the indexing case be particularly now
looking into techniques that we can
bound or find bounds for the arrows we
can get in the worst case so there's
this whole filter block about like
smooth analysis which allows you to get
like for certain types of models
guarantees and then you can say like
okay in the worst case I get the
following behavior right and like all my
model also grows like a b-tree like the
beach he gives you a strong guarantee
because you know in the moment goes like
out of balance you rebalance the whole
thing to get like the same look up
guarantee again you can there's some
machine learning models where you can do
something similar so like there is hope
for the new net stuff it's just like old
nuts right now like it's not much you
can do so you need to restrict the type
of smalls and some domains you can do
that and some others you have any
thoughts questions from the audience
well thank you all thank you very much
for a very entertaining session and
[Applause]